um
so when people ask me how did jackass
start i've got this distilled like i say
uh it started we were making
skateboarding videos
and
they just had all this crazy stuff in it
these skateboarding videos and then
they became very popular and the guy in
charge of making these skateboarding
videos reached out to his friend spike
jones and he said hey you know our
videos are getting so popular
but
like
it's not the skateboarding that people
are freaking out over it's all this
other crazy stuff and i think if we
subtract the skateboarding then what's
left over could be a tv show and when
you took out the skateboarding from the
big brother videos what you were left
with was knoxville wee man pontius and
bam was doing something similar so it
was like
it's pretty good yeah it's a skate video
without a whole lot of skating like well
big brother you know to be clear we were
the
our whole like right it was about
personalization very thin veil it was
about personalities the bigger the big
personalities in skateboarding more so
than the great skateboarding that's
happening you know i mean like it was
much more about finding the characters
and so
i i know that um
it's so funny how when jackass started
like they were still like let me do
dickhouse
is the production company responsible
for every
iteration of jackass and
when we started filming
the the tv show
like how clueless
to all levels of production like release
forms like you know we knew about
release forms i mean we knew about
release forms
we weren't very uh concerned about um
premise releases right uh
we weren't i did i knew we didn't have a
sound guy there was no sound guy there
was no sound guy in the first two
seasons in all the tv shows we never had
a sound guy like it was me taping a
microphone or something one or trip or
uh google even did that we put mics on a
lot of times
for pranks and and whatever for sending
somebody down the hill like when you
still box you had a [ __ ] mic on you i
don't even remember that we hurt you
guys a lot of times because we didn't
know where to put the [ __ ] little
metal box and when you fall on it it
sucks
and the sound was terrible i didn't know
that you could color correct
right so we were using
you know a couple of not i wouldn't call
professional cameras it was the pd-150
was our go-to camera which was a
professional-grade
dvr cam like it was somewhere in between
a skate camera it was better than the vx
1000 which was what all the skaters used
but it was the same camera just
it allowed it for a better mic or more
right right slightly more professional
and then handheld straight out of the
[ __ ] best buy you know i mean
i remember okay so
when uh i
i got so lucky that i i was fired from
like every job i had before jackass
because
when the pilot was going on for jackass
like i if i hadn't been fired i would
have missed out on it because i was on a
cruise ship working as a clown is that
when we shot them yeah yeah but but i
got i got fired
from my cruise ship job and i walked off
and i had saved like nine thousand bucks
over my six months did you get fired or
you just didn't i got i i i i
the the other clowns said to the the
brass of the cruise ship company they
said if stevo comes back for another
contract we all quit
you got pushed out yeah by a bunch of
jealous clowns it was it was a clown
mutiny yeah
so uh so and and i wasn't supposed to
know this i'd like like my boss clown he
said hey man i'm gonna tell you
something and if if it gets out that i
told you i'm gonna lose my job but i'm
just not gonna sit here and let these
clowns do you like this i'm telling you
up front like you're not coming back for
another contract they all went behind
your back and made this happen so it's
time for you to start calling up your
skateboard buddies and try to get
something and going with them
and so i knew ahead of time and i my
first call was to you i said jeff
i'm working on uh cruise ships as a
clown i'm always walking around on
stilts and it's like the biggest fear
i'm terrified while i'm walking on
stilts that uh that uh that i might fall
over
and so i gotta do it you know i gotta do
it and i'm thinking that if
i if i'm on stilts and i've got a big
still costume we set it on fire then i
can have a unicycle you know i did this
whole thing and uh i bought all the
[ __ ] equipment that still costumes
made all this all the equipment
none of the
really none of the fireproof equipment
that you would want to use in a
situation like that like right yeah this
is about
you have the stilts in the clown long
enough
to go over this thing right i bought
three sets of uh of a stilt clothes like
ten foot tall clothing costumes
and we set them all on fire i you know i
got the stilts i bought my airplane
tickets like i i [ __ ] spent all the
money i'd saved to go out to try to be
in big brother magazine
and
and and i didn't even know and so i get
out there and you're like okay now i'll
tell you this is for a pilot for him to
be right it was just me ballard and uh
i was there knoxville was there yeah
yeah did rick go i think maybe we had
rick i don't remember i don't remember
too much about i remember you went down
to danny ways yeah yeah um and that was
the first day i ever met knoxville this
happened on december 30th of 1999. we're
yeah so we you guys didn't know what
jackass was either right we didn't even
we didn't even i don't think had the
pilot deal done i think this was
pre-pilot to be honest we were just
gathering [ __ ] like you were in town you
wanted to do some [ __ ] so we went and
[ __ ] shot it
and uh
they did not so sat me down on a
hay bale and interviewed me
right right we didn't yeah we didn't we
never we didn't know what jackass was
well into filming jackass we still
didn't know right how is it gonna like
well doing the pilot we knew
uh [ __ ] it doesn't require a host right
yeah because we were at first like all
right we had these big brother videos
that people loved
and then
we got the tv show based on just cutting
together the funniest bits from those
some of bam [ __ ] right and a couple
other things off of like whiskey i think
i don't remember where i just sourced a
bunch of crazy [ __ ] but it all looked
like
jackass like uh
and and so we then we get the pilot like
we sell it to mtv
and we don't know how to we don't know
what it is still we're like we showed
this sizzle tape that they loved right
and then now we got the deal now we're
going to make a pilot all right do we
put knoxville behind a desk and you know
we're talking about we start thinking tv
you know like it should be a tv show
uh-huh and what we showed isn't a tv
show that's just a skate video right
right and then like so we start talking
about this and then spike just shut us
out he's like no just it just that's
what it is
you know what i mean you know what it is
it's great and so like he helped us like
gain confidence of stop thinking like
it's a tv show
it's just we sold it this is what it is
spike's like
got this annoying habit of being right
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]